[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker former nfl offensive lineman
of course the ross tucker football
podcast westwood one nfl analyst
and then he sent me this bombshell this
morning this tweet
are people nationally aware that the
steelers eagles penn state etc
and their opponents will evidently be
required to wear masks
while they're playing in pennsylvania
from now on
let's start there ross you got my
attention
yeah how are you dan thank you for
having me uh i'm back in your favorite
place by the way west point new york
georgia southern and army tomorrow
looking forward to it
yeah so uh as you can see from my shirt
uh
my high school's in the state semi-final
tomorrow
so i've been following this closely on
wednesday
governor tom wolf had four new uh
mandates to help slow the spread of the
coronavirus
one of which was evidently you
still have to you now have to wear masks
inside
if you have someone over to your house
but also any athletic competition
during the athletic competition
evidently you
you have to have a mask on and what's
kind of
funny about it dan is later that day
this is all happened wednesday
later that day i think the steelers said
we have an
exemption for that so then yesterday the
news people
asked the governor's office do the
steelers have an exemption
and the governor's office said no they
don't have an exemption nobody has an
exemption
so right now the understanding is
everyone in the state of pennsylvania
during athletic competition
will be required to wear a mask however
i've seen the local
pia say it's really up to the
school districts and their solicitors to
decide how they handle it so
it's very very interesting and what i
what i don't like about it
dan is anytime you talk about something
like this
it feels like it gets political right
you know on the one hand
i don't think wearing a mask or a gator
is that big a deal i've talked to some
college kids at miami ohio or whatever
they've worn one
in in practice all year on the other
hand
we now have between australia and europe
the united states
thousands and thousands of games and
there's still
no evidence of transmission during play
so it doesn't really seem like this
mandate would actually be following the
science or the data so
it's a bit of a conundrum okay the
steelers and eagles i think are both on
the road
uh so they they would have a a week to
work this out if this is going to be
implemented
with the nfl does that sound correct
yeah i mean obviously the steelers
thought it already was worked out they
play thanksgiving against the ravens
thanksgiving night
there are high school playoff games
tonight and i think penn state pitt
and temple might all have home games
tomorrow so
i don't know i mean it's on tv you know
i'm sure that some of these games they
can say well we're not wearing it
they're not gonna
it's hard to enforce but when you're on
tv they kind of
have pretty good evidence that you're
not doing it yeah well then you have the
situation with the raiders
the raiders have 11 players who have
tested positive they have this game
against kansas city
why hasn't this game been moved it felt
like when stefan gilmore tested positive
for the patriots
they moved their thursday night game how
are they going to be and like at what
point
is it too many players for the raiders
to be able to play this game against
kansas city
yeah so my understanding dan and i might
be wrong on this
is that most of those guys are just
close contacts of one person that tested
positive so
i think a lot of them are going to come
off the covered list tomorrow
and sunday so i think most of those guys
should be able to play sunday night
they just haven't been able to practice
all week and the nfl has decided that
that is okay
that's acceptable for guys to not
practice but still playing the game heck
it worked for roethlisberger
last week uh for the steelers and
there's just there's no more bi-week
stand i mean
there's no more uh opportunity i think
at some point
there's no doubt in my mind the nfl went
from hey there's a couple guys that
can't play
we should you know try to reschedule it
to you know what
this is just going to be part of it this
is part of the competitive situation
this year don't be a high risk contact
don't do things that
cause you to get coveted and we're just
gonna roll with it
if you were an offensive lineman on the
saints would you rather have jameis
winston or taysom hill
for this weekend's game oh
uh you know i haven't seen
taysom hill play quarterback enough
to really be able to answer that
i guess i'd probably rather have jameis
i think
that he'd probably be able to get rid of
the ball quicker but
i don't know about that i do know this
though dan i think it's interesting
you know the saints gave tyson hill a
one-year extension
as a restricted free agent that's 21
million dollars
between last year and this year i kind
of assumed or thought
that that was because they thought he
had a great chance to be the heir
apparent to drew brees
but now this will be the second year in
a row that drew brees gets hurt
and they're putting in another
quarterback instead of him i guess
they value him that much as a gadget guy
and also because jameis is only under
contract for one year
they wanted to make sure they had at
least some option
one option under contract for 2021 i
guess i understand that
he's ross tucker former nfl offensive
lineman ross tucker football podcast and
an analyst for westwood one
also on the call this saturday at noon
georgia southern at
west point all right let me go to the
thursday night game
what we saw with seattle's defense stood
out more than anything else
is this a one-off or is this what is
this how seattle is going to be trying
to play the rest of the season
you know what they've actually been
pretty decent on defense
three out of the last four games with
the exception of that buffalo bills game
seattle has played better on the
defensive side of the ball
we saw carlos dunlap who they got from
the bengals
was a huge factor in the game last night
and i do think it's funny greg cosell
from nfl films and i were debating this
on the ross tucker podcast this morning
i do
think greg when they run the ball uh
craig dan
when they run the ball a little bit and
keep the defense fresh on the sideline
that it does help them you know i think
they realize that just
trying to have russell wilson be the
hero and throw four or five touchdown
passes every week
it's really really hard to do so running
the ball a little bit helps russell
and it's not as many snaps for the
defense and that d-line was able to get
after kyla murray
a lot better as a result and troy aikman
during the game
said defenses aren't going to just sit
back and let
kyler murray kind of dictate that maybe
defenses are going to start to go
all out put a little more pressure on
him and seattle did that they disrupted
his pocket a little bit more and they
sort of dictated
if he was going to run when he was going
to run and if he was going to throw
it's easier said than done but can you
see that as a blueprint moving forward
with defenses with kyler
absolutely look if you just let him drop
back and pass hey he's a really good
passer
but b there will eventually be a scene
and he will find it and he's the
quickest quarterback one of the quickest
nfl players
i have ever seen he's gonna find i think
the philosophy a little bit is
go get him before he gets you
and really both he and the cardinals boy
they had some critical errors last night
there i mean think about the end of the
first half right
he slides a yard short of the first down
on second and fourth otherwise they
would have kept the ball they probably
would have gotten the field goal didn't
happen third down he doesn't give it to
kenyon drake
they have to punt and the seahawks get a
field goal at the end of the first half
then late in the game he has that
critical
intentional grounding the next play is a
holding penalty in the end zone for a
safety by sweezie
that was five points that really came
down to what i would consider
mental errors by tyler murray why is the
sports media so obsessed with carson
wentz
you know i i'm probably the wrong person
to answer this because
i live outside of philadelphia and i do
eagles tv
and eagles radio so i mean that's all i
know i didn't know it was national i i
know that's the way it is in
philadelphia
for sure i think for whatever reason
he's become a really polarizing player
you know 2017 he probably would have
been the mvp of the league
and they might have won the super bowl
with him but
they didn't so he doesn't get credit for
that
and it feels like he's kind of gotten a
little bit worse
each year and this year certainly he has
struggled
so now and then the eagles drafted jalen
hurts
which uh added intrigue to the situation
so there are people you know it's a
really interesting thing dan i know you
know this right
but it's hard to get people to come off
their original take or their original
opinion of someone and so many people
went in on the
carson wentz top five quarterback carson
wentz
mvp that they're gonna fight that
they're gonna hold on to that
as long as they can even though
unfortunately for the eagles
he clearly has not been that guy this
year but how much blame do we put on him
and is jalen hurts an upgrade if you put
him in there now
so i think that wentz deserves a lot of
blame this year and and i'm a big fan of
his
personally and professionally they've
had a lot of guys out but he's had
so many turnovers this year so many
really
ugly surprising turnovers where he's
trying to do too much
and but the thing that dan is probably
the scariest for the eagles and eagles
fans
you know last sunday giants
mile sanders was back al shawn jeffrey
was back
lane johnson was back and by the way
carson wentz didn't turn it over i mean
he didn't turn it over so there was no
sort of a
crutch or excuse for why the eagles lost
they just got beat i mean the giants
were just better the giants are just the
better team in that game
they won by ten so all of the sort of
built-in excuses about injuries or
turnovers
they all went out the window so now
eagles fans are kind of like
wait a minute now what now are we just
not good
i i love the way the giants play you
know
they may not be a great team but they
play hard
and it feels like every week they're
they're getting better
i don't know if they steal this division
but nothing would surprise me in the nfc
east i just don't think the eagles are a
good team right now i don't think
they're well coached right now
the cowboys are a mess right now
washington's a mess
and here are the giants without saquon
barkley
and they might be the best team in the
division the second half of the season
i agree uh they certainly were on sunday
you know they've lost so many close
games they've been joe
judge has them in every game they easily
could have five or six wins right now
when you think about all the cowboys
game and
the bucks game i mean all these close
losses
joe judge did a nice job with that team
the defense
is much improved daniel jones two games
in a row
without turning it over right now i
think they are the best team in the nfc
east the only thing i would say and i've
been saying this all week
is this is exactly when the eagles win
i mean four years in a row 2017
18 19 just when er
just when all the eagles fans are like
i'm done with them
i'm not watching anymore the season's
over they somehow win when you least
suspect it
and figure out a way to win the division
or go to the playoffs and maybe even
make a run so we'll see big game against
cleveland on sunday
great to talk to you ross thank you
enjoy uh west point
army against georgia's southern coming
up at noon eastern on cbs sports network
thank you buddy
my pleasure always that's ross tucker
former nfl offensive lineman in the ross
tucker football podcast where you can
learn something
westwood won nfl analyst